[Music]
Queens in New York is the worst infected
district in what is now the world's
worst infected city and the doctors and
nurses don't know what's hit them how is
it help Biblical I kid you not
people come in I get intubated they die
the cycle repeats the whelmed
yeah the system's overwhelmed all over
the place my daughter's an intern in
Brooklyn
first-year resident she starts the ICU
today I couldn't sleep last night it's
it's scary
they are overrun in this hospital so
stretched that an area of the waiting
room has been screened off to make a
temporary ward in an internal email the
chief medical officer told staff
it was the humanitarian mission of their
lifetime right now it's everyday it's
nonstop literally and unfortunately it's
might get to situation you have to pick
and choose what you're gonna do how
you're gonna do and as the doctor said a
lot of people come they're not really
survive they expire and you put the same
machine in another person and you cannot
really even cope with the situation
because it's so hard to think about this
and we try to do our best the only thing
I ask everyone I know you guys from
England we live in the States stay at
home if you don't need to go anywhere
don't try to do anything crazy right now
it's a serious pandemic every hospital
or Medical Center we go to is flat-out
New York a city no stranger to disaster
could be on the cusp of something it has
never experienced before 9/11 was
nothing compared to this we were open
waiting for patients to come who never
came okay now they just keep coming and
they're all ages don't delude yourself
into thinking only the old will die or
we'll get it they're all ages but like
9/11 it is New York's doctors nurses
paramedics and first responders who are
putting other lives ahead of their own
the number of confirmed cases is going
up here by about 5,000 every single day
and they're just about coping and think
this is one of the most advanced medical
systems in the world here but what is
becoming quite clear is New York is
reaching a tipping point and far sooner
than anyone here expected
Queens is where Donald Trump grew up
he's repeatedly described this health
crisis as a war well now his home town
is on the front line
Alistair bunker Sky News New York